[Musique]
nous devons faire preuve d'audace dans
nos valeurs et également les décliner de
façon à ce qu'on parle au monde que les
gens disent ok oui
en ce sens-là c'est notre défi on en est
pleinement conscient
[Musique]
4 CV qui était un
vecteur ici aux élections de 2022 ce qui
espérait obtenir plus de détails sur les
règles pour la prochaine course à la
direction devront patienter le comité de
réflexion vient tout juste de commencer
ses travaux le rapport est attendu à
l'automne aurait-il fallu adopter une
approche plus rapide les jeunes libéraux
Québécois pensent que oui j'ai en ma
compagnie la présidente de la commission
jeunesse du Parti libéral Laurence
Lefèvre merci d'être avec nous merci
Laurence il aurait fallu une course plus
rapide
je pense que personnellement pour qu'on
puisse relancer et c'est redonné de la
vie aux parties je crois que ça serait
bénéfique mais j'ai fait passer mon
message il y a maintenant deux mois puis
même si on a comité de relance qui va
nous permettre de brasser les idées mais
en même temps le brassage idée avant
d'avoir un chef est-ce que c'est pas de
mettre un peu la charrue devant les buts
je penserai pas je pensais être un
exercice qui était nécessaire en termes
de
repenser nos valeurs c'est nos valeurs
la dernière fois qui ont été pensées ils
sont juste en 2002 moi personnellement
j'avais deux ans donc les choses ont pas
mal changé depuis ce temps-là donc je
pense pas qu'il faut attendre d'avoir un
nouveau chef pour faire ce brossage
nos valeurs il faut qu'elle reflète le
Québec
vision du chef qui s'inscrit aussi de
l'orientation que le parti va prendre
c'est pour ça que je me disais est-ce
que c'est pas un peu complexe de dire ok
orientons le parti maintenant puis
qu'arrive-t-il si chef ou le prochain
chef il débarque puis moi je préférais
qu'on aille dans cette direction là mais
le comité de relance le n'établit pas
une plateforme électorale je pense que
c'est là que le chef notre prochain chef
pour mettre la direction un petit peu
plus c'est comme ou elle le voudra donc
c'est le comité de relance c'est
vraiment pour penser nos valeurs et non
établir une plateforme électorale vous
parliez de réflexion tout à l'heure de
de revoir un peu dans le fond c'est
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'être un libéral
en 2023 qu'est-ce que c'est que un
libéral en 2023 d'après vous mais pour
moi être libéral lors de mes 23 c'est
vouloir un Québec qui est plus vert plus
prospère un Québec qui pense aussi à son
économie
tout en continuant justement de trouver
l'équilibre entre un équilibre
budgétaire un équilibre économique mais
aussi continuer d'offrir des services
aux citoyens du Québec et non coupé puis
aller justement piger dans le fond des
générations pour donner des baisses
d'impôts des choses comme ça pourquoi
pourquoi parce qu'on avait l'impression
que c'était ça que vous proposiez lors
de la dernière campagne une espèce
d'équilibre
tant du côté vert que du côté économique
pourquoi ça peut raisonné puis qu'est-ce
qu'il faut changer par rapport à ça
honnêtement je pense que on était un peu
tasse longtemps qu'on n'aurait pas
établi justement c'est quoi être libéral
c'est quoi nos valeurs enfin 23 on se
repend en mesure de raisonner avec le
public en général je pense que justement
la dernière élection on était un peu
perdu on savait pas c'était quoi
maintenant identité donc oui on est
capable de démontrer clairement l'écart
de montrer qu'on peut avoir une
plateforme qui est de manière qui est
équilibrée entre le changement
climatique sauver l'environnement mais
aussi pas faire des coupures partout
mais on n'avait pas une vision claire de
qui nous étions on est un peu plus perdu
je pensais ce qu'on va être qui va
falloir qu'on travaille avant si on veut
être élu en 206 les jeunes que vous
représentez ils se définissent comment
ils veulent quoi de la formation
politique qui veulent croire du Parti
libéral ben il y a plusieurs enjeux
qu'on veut en entendre plus c'est clair
l'environnement il faut qu'on s'y
attaque mais aussi l'éducation il faut
il faut faire des changements
on veut repartir
qui continue défendre l'environnement
mais qui aussi défend l'économie qui
assure que les générations futures ne
seront pas laissées abandonnés
ce qui est toujours très présent c'est
moi ou je peux parler de la Commission
jeunesse là hier au Conseil on avait
plus de 70 jeunes présents ce qui est
une présence remarquable de jeunes c'est
surtout sans mettre ton regard la
présence jeune au congrès de la carte la
semaine dernière et autres congrès c'est
donc militantisme va très bien les idées
continuent de bouger on a des élus qui
sont exceptionnels qui continuent de
brosser la cage à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est toujours difficile une défaite
électorales et et les gens la traînent
longtemps est-ce que est-ce que vous
êtes passé par dessus ce que la page est
tourné ou pas encore complètement mais
justement hier c'était l'occasion de
tourner la page puis ouvrir un nouveau
chapitre
ça sera toujours difficile une perte
historique comme ça mais reste que hier
on a lancé
un nouveau chapitre on lance l'été pour
justement conseiller consultations avec
un comité de relance du parti et puis on
regarde vers l'avant puis moi je l'ai
senti que nos militants sont prêts à
regarder vers le vampire regardez voir
notre élections merci beaucoup merci à
vous